President Biden said to give a prime
time address just 3 hours from now on
the wars in Israel and Ukraine and the
stakes could not be higher Israel's uh
defense minist minister telling ground
troops at the border with Gaza to
prepare to invade and that they would
soon see Gaza from the inside prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu out on the
front lines to Rally his troops we are
going to win full force the entire
people of Israel is standing behind you
and we will give the blow to our enemies
so we get to victory victory the Middle
East continues to be a powder keg
protest erupting all over as they buy
the Hamas lie blaming Israel for the
hospital blast it's so bad that the
state department is issuing a worldwide
caution travel alert for Americans but
don't worry Joe Biden says he is going
to settle all the chaos the president
boasting that his trip to Israel was a
big success while making some awkward
gaps about Hamas
missiles if the if Hamas confiscated
Ates it or doesn't let it get through
just confiscates it then it's going to
end I came to get something done I got
it done if if I didn't if I wasn't able
to make it into the into Israel I got it
done people all over the region um are
upset about the hospital and don't
necessarily believe uh you or the
Israelis that they didn't have anything
to do with it I'm not suggesting that
Hamas deliberately did it either that's
that old thing got to known how to shoot
straight uh you know and uh and it's not
the first time Hamas has launched
something that didn't
function Biden is also facing brand new
questions over100 million in
humanitarian assistant for Gaza SEC
Senator Rick Scott says you can bet it
will all end up in the hands of Hamas
terrorists you're not you're not helping
them you're not helping them you're
helping Hamas you're helping the
Palestinian Authority I mean you're
given money to get to help Hamas to go
kill more babies and and destroy more
babies and Destroy more families that's
exactly what you're doing all right
Jesse uh Biden says they got to learn to
shoot straight does he understand really
what that meant that if they were
shooting straight they would kill more
people or is this just a it's a
colloquialism
and I even I have a hard time sometimes
criticizing him because I don't think he
meant exactly that they have to shoot
straight yes but but tonight he has to
make it relevant to us is he just going
to go and do an oval office address to
ask for money because he can always ask
for money what is the Biden Doctrine is
it just don't don't don't how does this
relate to energy prices how does it
relate to the supply chain is he going
to bring up the fact that the border is
insecure no he's just going to ask for
money and then he's going to say we have
to take on autocracies we have to take
on terrorism and America is the leader
of the Free World rah rah rah I don't
think the American people are really in
the mood for that kind of speech right
now we'll probably give them the money
the Senate will give it to him the house
will give it to him doesn't matter but
he has to put it in the context of why
is this important to us and he's never
really been able to do that this is not
a good venue for him matter of fact most
venues are not good venues for him he's
not a great or an eloquent speaker
recently he's been squinting a lot and
mumbling a lot and you can really tell
the difference
qualitatively when he went to the back
with the Press On Air Force One that was
probably the worst I'd ever seen them in
a long time so I shouldn't expect much
the American people shouldn't expect
much tonight the
um I just think I just think it's an odd
request to take prime time and I'm not
just talking about my show talking about
Network Prime Time real estate to ask
for money it doesn't make sense to me it
feels wor but you know we'll listen see
what he says judge about the age should
he just write don't on the aid packages
just that that'll be a forceful message
that'll scare Hamas you know my thoughts
on what he may say tonight are a little
more focused on the War I don't want
Israel to be used as a reason to give
Ukraine more money we've already given
Ukraine 113 billion last week a week ago
exactly we gave him another 200 million
and now he's talking about 100 million
for Ukraine 40 for Israel he gave a 100
million for Gaza for the Palestinians I
don't want Israel to be responsible to
make sure that that food and that Aid
goes to the Palestinians because Hamas
is the one who's in charge I don't want
Joe Biden telling Israel how to fight
this war and when they should fight and
when they shouldn't given the fact that
we are now on the verge of a multi-front
war we know now that Hezbollah is
flexing its muscles we know now that the
Israeli and the uh Arabs and the West
Bank are are are getting uh energized
also Biden because of what has happened
must prove to the world tonight that it
was not Israel that that uh threw a bomb
at a hospital I want to ask you Greg
have you seen a bombed out hospital has
anyone at this table seen it has anyone
seen a bag of 500 uh Palestinian body
bags 300 even now they're saying it's
between 10 and 50 all right there's no
bomb crater I talked about this
yesterday there's the the fuel that
caused the fire is in a parking lot next
to a courtyard next to a hospital and
yet the world is ready to go on fire to
believe a lie that Joe Biden could put
the truth to it immediately and Israel
is a victim here not Hamas so I want the
the the president to claw back the six
billion I want him to call out Iran I
want him to say want those hostages back
and today you mentioned the state
department has issued a worldwide alert
travel alert to Americans I want Joe
Biden to issue a travel alert to the
world none of you are coming here
anymore we're done with everybody and I
want him to take the FBI off the
Catholics off the parents and off the
political enemies I want him in the chat
rooms I want them online I want them to
find the threats to Americans that they
missed with the Boston Bomber San
Bernardino the pulse nightclub and I
want the world to respect this again
there you go so Shannon what do you
expect to hear what would you like to
hear I think that he's going to have to
be brutally honest with the American
people about actually what's going on um
when you we hear this afternoon axios is
reporting that artillery shells we were
going to give to Ukraine now have to be
diverted to the Israelis because they
say we desperately and urgently need
them and it's not just those two places
you know there are think tanks in
Washington that track just how far we
have depleted all kinds of armaments and
ammo and all kinds of things they say it
could take 5 to 10 years to restock
those and don't forget we have the
Taiwan China situation because Taiwan
has ordered multiple millions of dollars
of things from us we're not delivering
them we can't do it so I think that the
president's going to have to speak
honestly with the American people he's
been out there saying we can handle
things on multiple friends secretary
Austin and others we can do multiple
things at one time but the fact is we
don't have unlimited resources there are
going to be difficult choices and as
early as this afternoon seeing this
transfer instead of Ukraine to Israel
he's gonna have to level with the
American people so they can trust that
he's being honest all right Jessica what
do you think he's gonna say and what say
well I know that he's going to
disappoint judge Pio because it's too
many things for one address I mean
you're going back to what happened in
the Boston bombing and and I understand
these are all things that are relevant
but not particularly to this moment I
would like it to be actually quite
narrow in terms of what's going on with
the October 7th Israel war
and then what the implications are for
America to your point Jesse why should
we care he already has the American
people behind him if you look at the
support for Israel it is through the
roof except with younger voters so
people 25 and under and we we've talked
a lot about how that's kind of exploding
online and proliferating so much
disinformation about what has happened
here but he has to make it relevant for
us he has to explain why this money is
deserved how it protects our interests
um that we have one Ally in the one true
Ally in the Middle East we can make
friends with Saudi Arabia as it pleases
and we can do deals with them but it's
Israel for us and I do think he sent
such an enormously strong message to the
World by going there this is now the
second war zone that a man who I hear
can't find his own pants was able to
visit then he gets on a plane he does
three or four hours with the Press which
is something that he doesn't usually do
and I maybe he was low energy for you
but he did spend the time to talk to
them to listen to all their questions
and then he comes back and he does an
oval address
something that is incredibly important
um that I'm sure that he will use to be
able to make his case to the American
people but he has defied expectations I
think on every single front of these the
Israelis are thrilled BB Netanyahu is
talking about he couldn't have a better
partner for this and he's talking about
Republican and Democratic
administrations um in terms of the Gaza
Aid 100 million dollars is a lot of
money but you also have to consider the
fact that the UN has made it clear that
Israel has now committed war crimes that
that's what's going on in Gaza so they
say that Hamas committed war crimes on
the Israel side and now if you let two
million people Sans the ones who have
already died I think it's 1500 gazin
have already passed away from this if
you don't even make the effort to try to
get humanitarian Aid to them then Joe
Biden becomes a president that oversaw w
war crimes so he has to message that and
what the IDF what the Israelis do with
that message whether they end up sending
it in or not not but he had to signal to
the American people and to the world
that he cares about all innocent humans
on both sides of these I think I think
his message could be extremely simple if
I were president and some say I already
am uh you have to bring Clarity to this
situation right we're dealing in the
here and now we're not dealing with
history right you can't change history
especially one that goes back centuries
this is why the passion of the co-eds
comes off as so idiotic that somebody
born in 2005 somehow has a solution that
for centuries has vexed Humanity these
these kids can barely bathe you know so
history is often used to justify the
present day Horrors it's a game with no
end there's a reason for that so I think
if he's watching and he probably is
because he loves the five repeat after
me we're dealing with now and not
history octo the attack on October 7th
that is here that is now deal with it is
Israel is dealing with it and we're
right behind them that's all you have to
say it's going to be quick yeah there
you go I did it for be on by 803
actually I won't I'll be at dinner hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now